epa administrator scott pruett is
drawing praise and scorn after stepping
down in the face of numerous ethic
ethics probes in a letter Pruitt told
President Trump it was an honor and a
blessing to serve in the cabinet and
called his decision to resign extremely
difficult Paula Reid is in Berkeley
Heights New Jersey near the Golf Club
where the president is spending the
weekend Paula good morning good morning
last night aboard Air Force One on his
way to Montana the president spoke with
reporters where he had nothing but
praise for Pruitt and he said that it
was Pruitt and floated the idea of
resignation because he no longer wanted
to be a distraction well president Trump
spoke of the winning ways of his
presidency he was losing his fifth
cabinet official EPA Administrator Scott
Pruett questions about Pruitt successive
office spending first-class air travel
and treatment of staff had Washington
investigators working overtime Pruett
was the subject of a House Oversight
Committee investigation v Inspector
General audits seven pending inspector
general reviews and two Government
Accountability Office increase in his
resignation letter Pruitt wrote that he
was leaving in part because the
unrelenting attacks on me personally my
family are unprecedented and have taken
a sizable toll on all of us on Monday
Pruitt was confronted by a sixth grade
teacher at a Washington restaurant
under fire for flying first class at
taxpayer expense Pruitt told major
Garrett in February that it was because
of security concerns these threats have
been unprecedented from the very
beginning and the quantity and type are
impressive in it tweeting about the
resignation President Trump said
Pruitt's deputy Andrew wheeler will
continue on with our great and lasting
APA agenda that worries
environmentalists who say wheeler a
former coal lobbyist will pick up
exactly where Pruitt left off favoring
the fossil fuel industry over the
environment
Bob Dean's of the Natural Resources
Defense Council he has done everything
he can to prevent us from doing anything
to protect our children from the growing
dangers of climate change during his
confirmation hearing for that deputy
position wheeler was pressed on his
views on climate change and he testified
he does believe that humans have had an
impact on the climate but the full
extent of that impact is not completely
understood
bianna Paula thank you